[Musique]
est-ce que tout de même pour beaucoup de
gens car nous avons ici de deux
représentants du mlf
jacqueline zag c'est vous autres du mlf
qui avait lancé le l'histoire du 8 mars
est ce que ce n'est pas un peu l'image
que vous avez donnée de vous dans le
grand public c'est à dire des femmes
assez violente à la limite de l'hystérie
qui réclamait la castration de tous les
hommes non je crois que c'est l'image
que les médias
c'est à dire des gens comme vous ont
voulu donner du mls comme moi je ne sens
pas responsable
une personne ya des agents qui avaient
tout à fait intérêt à ce que le mlf
apparaissent comme ces castratrice un
peu virago un peu benoîte mais ceci dit
moi je n'ai pas vu le film alors je ne
peux pas dire comment elle est l'intérêt
de vouloir répéter cette image des
femmes alors que vous savez comme tous
les téléspectateurs qui regardent qu'il
y a maintenant des mouvements de
libération des femmes dans tous les pays
c'est à dire des femmes qui existe qui
disent que les femmes ça existe qu'il y
à des femmes que ce n'est pas ça et que
les femmes sont fortes et parce qu'elles
sont fortes ce n'est pas correctement
dans le premier film dont vous avez vu
vous avez parlé
ce n'est pas parce qu'elles sont fortes
que ça va priver des hommes elles sont
fortes ça n'enlève rien à personne ça
apporte bien alors une question je
voudrais poser sur ce fameux 8 mars et
que j'ai entendu dire et je les lui ce
matin dans un article une pétroleuse qui
éclaire gallois dans le figaro
et puis d'autres bol ont dit que ce
fameux 8 mars il paraît que c'est une
invention qu'il n'y a jamais une grève
dans l'histoire et qu'en plus c'est une
invention stalinienne car finalement ce
serait staline qui aurait créé le jour
de la femme à battre je crois que c'est
mais qui est de cet avis mais pécresse
vous avez
si vous êtes bien entendu parler de la
grève donc donc fait mention oui mais
que jamais elle était une invention pure
et simple
c'est une émotion historique qui
pourrait décourager malgré cela c'est
une question fasse des manifestations
celui absolument d'accord mais quand ce
rôle comptes comprennent qu'on se base
sur une grève pour manifester ce jour-là
c'est tout nommé il ya une accusation
plus grave dans le journal ce matin
c'est que vous auriez choisi finalement
la date du 8 mars est donc une fête dans
les pays de l'est et qui aurait s'est
décidée par staline
un peu comme on pourrait dire que la
fête des mères a été décidée par pétain
c'est un petit peu ça l'a redit oui
écouter oui je crois je pense que ça va
marcher dans l'histoire du micro new
bond à la marche mais on se donne la
bannière de la parole puis à quelqu'un
qui est arrivé à bord allez-y vous êtes
du mlf aussi marocain bac tu avais un
fruit bon pour la question de vue mars
c'est effectivement une
date que nous reprenons parce que c'est
une date historique les ouvrières new
yorkaise sont descendus dans la rue pour
obtenir d'avoir les mêmes salaires et
les mêmes le temps de travail que les
hommes mais sinon non merci
oui je crois que là non non il n'y a pas
de n'y a pas de doute il n'y a pas de
recette david et maigret quand même
nommé boire ça veut dire bon en suisse
je connais très bien à vis des
magouilles man qui a été une militante
féministe est un art schiste aux états
unis et qui parle de tous les mouvements
de grève qui ont existé et la seule
cette date là n'existe pas de service
gisèle va vous avez une information à
donner enfin dire plusieurs choses
ce ne sont pas les paroles c'est parle
de niche qui dit qu émancipation de la
femme celle annette et steve d'une femme
enfin de la dégénérescence de la femme
et du féminisme ça ces niches qui l'a
dit ce n'est pas moi
alors vous parlez grève jamais un truc
et c'est pas moi qui les ai cherchés
sont des femmes qui m'ont apporté
alors voilà l'appel du mlf du 8 mars
jour férié jours chômés payés pour tous
ouais on s'est vraiment triste d'en
arriver là j'ai une chaussée à mener
j'ai amené enfin je veux pas dire les
noms mais enfin bon on le met comme ça
c'est un journal qui s'appelle comment j
sais pas qui est vraiment très féministe
qu'il était que l'étaient les théories
attendant avant à venir qui était très
que les ministres aient vraiment il y
avait une véhémence sur l'homme qui
était pas possible
et comme par hasard certainement il n'y
a pas tellement de lectrices il a changé
de nom il s'appelle le nouveau f
alors si je prends le sommaire du
nouveau f
voilà quelques quelques semaines que je
peux trouver l'art de vivre ses
angoisses à marie pour 3500 francs
le désir pourquoi ne pas le dire alors
là il ya eu une enquête je veux pas
rentrer dans cette enquête mais enfin
c'est très drôle
ensuite on change la romaine qui inventa
l'amour voilà
et enfin pour que ce soit la femme
parfaite on en arrive le surgelé et ses
jouets voilà qui je n'ai pas eu peur de
vous présenter dans plus vous êtes
ingénieur mais vous êtes surtout fait
remarquer dans une émission
d'aujourd'hui madame il ya quelques
temps pour avoir parlé de votre vie de
séducteur et ouais enfin on m'a attribué
ce truc de séducteur enfin moi je suis
célibataire j'ai 35 ans allait paraît
peut-être
vous assumez comme bon c'est pas bien
compris vous voulez en faisait lorsqu'il
voit ce que je voulais en venir entre
l'image de l'appel à la grève des femmes
les sommaires des magazines ou les en
venir avec le féminisme n'a aucune
chance et je pense qu'on va l'enterrer
c'est à vous d'en descendre attendait
alors il ya une autre
oui j'adore les femmes mais je n'aime
pas du tout les féminines elle qui m'a
fait choisir
oui parce qu'on voulait à vos pieds pour
demander vous faisons mais je vous
demande quoi parce que de nom non mais
de toute manière de jouer
laissez-moi dessus on attire deux jours
je vais vous savez on a rien là vous
envie vraiment rien non j'avais une
chose qui l'envié de vous dire que si
ceux ci nous sommes là à nous militons
tout pour une cause à titre collectif à
titre personnel et je veux dire que si
les hommes ne changent pas si n'essaye
pas de comprendre le pourquoi plutôt que
parler du féminisme essayer de les
écouter
eh bien je crois qu'ils vont pas se
sentir longtemps bien dans leurs baskets
sur 60% des divorces ont demandé par les
femmes
bientôt il y en aura 100 % ont peut-être
se marieront plus le nombre des mères
célibataires volontaires augmente ça
veut dire quelque chose ça ne vous
interpelle pas quelque part sinon vous
réponse la vie
odile dhavernas vous êtes encore d'un
autre mouvement féministe comme à 400 en
france j'ai l'impression au miami de
mouvements vire il y en a pas on n'en a
pas besoin
je vais pouvoir y arriver aux enfants
tous les joueurs n'ont pas bien passé
pour moi amour un mot sur les gens qui
sont derrière moi des titres différents
d'ailleurs d'abord pour ce monsieur qui
parle là vous nous l'avez présenté au
début d'émission comme étant un
phallocrate et se donnent en effet du
monde pour justifier ce que vous avez
dit non pas au naturel pas du tout loupé
en exprimant des idées phallocrate des
idées on en attend encore un an n'a pas
entendu mais en tout cas pour donner
l'impression du phallocrate alors moi
c'est à vous que je pose une question
michel polac parce que je suis tout de
même étonné que dans une émission
concernant les femmes ou les femmes vont
parler d'elle même de leur situation
vous nous disiez voilà j'ai invité à
phallocrate et je vous demande
simplement si vous imagineriez à la
télévision d'invités et noir ou voie
nord africains où un juif et puis un
raciste un raciste de venir faire
discuter tranquillement le raciste avec
le noir ou le gif pour savoir qui a
raison et qui a tort et le faire se
justifier des noirs ou des who d'oracle
anglais de discuter effectivement les
races sont l inégale et ses rails et
mieux je crois pas moi j'imagine ça très
mal à la télévision française
notre émission je vais parler je crois
que c'est une façon de montrer aussi
même s'il est tout seul mais je sens
qu'on est parti pour l'entendre ce soir
parce qu'il tient beaucoup à faire en
tant que c'est une façon de montrer que
la phallocratie encore tout à fait droit
de cité dans la société et à la télé si
elles existent encore jeudi j'ai dit un
seul mot qu'elle existe jeudi qu'elle a
droit de cité
il peut l'être remarque aussi en sache
quels sont les gens qui sont là de
quelle manière ça se passe alors par
rapport aux personnes qui vous disent
qu'elles sont du mlf je voudrais juste
faire une remarque que personne ne s'y
trompe
elles vous disent qu'elles représentent
même élève je réponds simplement qu'elle
représente le mlf comme monsieur
représente huiles lesieur
parce que le groupement a déposé une
marque de commerce qui s'appelle mlf et
par conséquent ce sont des représentants
de commerce mais le mlf mouvement de
libération des femmes comporte un nombre
de groupes très nombreux très divers
elles ne sont qu'un pas remis
groupe et il est tout à fait
inadmissible qu'elle représente et
prétendent en représenter l'ensemble
mais les fans je signerai candide la
menace est avocat qu'elle a publié
plusieurs livres et que son dernier défi
sur du saï saï même petite soeur née
près par suicide
voici ce livre est le mlf réponse est
oui alors justement j'avais remarqué
depuis le début qu'il n'était question
ici que des mouvements féministes et pas
du tout du mlf or là nous sommes deux
femmes de mon libération des femmes
je voulais prévenir d'une caverne à ce
qu'il fallait qu'elle fasse quand même
attention à ce qu'elle dit parce que
c'est tout à fait les diffamations et
qu'on a décidé et qu'on a décidé en
effet de ne pas laisser dire n'importe
quoi alors le mouvement libération des
femmes en quoi nous disons prenez pas
non j'aimerais que ce soir on arrive par
exemple à discuter de la question de
fond c'est à dire la question du
féminisme ou par du féminisme et de la
libération des femmes parce que c'est
effectivement pas la même chose
alors est ce que c'est possible d'en
parler ça c'est bien sûr marie cardinal
ce que je veux dire c'est que moi qui me
vont courir je mens totalement d'humour
quand il s'agit de parler de la cause
des femmes car je trouve que c'est la
cause la plus importante de l'humanité
la plus importante
je ne crois pas qu'il y ait une cause
politique plus grave au sens du
politique c'est à dire l'organisation de
la société
je pense qu'il y à des courants parmi
nous les femmes et que si nous avons du
linge sale nous devons le laver entre
nous et subissez ce genre de querelles
qui ne peut que porter tort à notre
cause qui est la meilleure qui la cause
des vieux qui est la cause des enfants
et qui est la cause de toutes les femmes
c'est à dire des quatre cinquièmes de
l'humanité
c'est une autre humanité que nous
voulons qu'ils est une c'est une c'est
une cause i mean amant politique il n'y
a pas de cause plus grave il ne
l'obtiendront pas une démocratie tant
que cette cause là ne sera pas entendue
dans l'atelier
merci marica ordina oui amusés
lorsqu'ils auraient en effet alors je me
demande comment un groupe ii
deux femmes parmi tant d'autres dans ses
mouvements des femmes dans tout ou en
partie s'arrogent le droit de se nommer
ainsi
mais le parle il ya de la place il y a
de la place pour tout le monde et tout
ici tout est richard est l'âme du
féminisme leçons et en été c'est parce
que notre mouvement et c'est important
que monsieur je ne sais pas son nom
oui il y à une loi antiraciste qui
condamne certains propos contre non mais
je rigole oui vous rigolez mais ils ont
presque tout le monde rigole avec à ce
que je vois la zizanie entre vous et je
reviens pas le menu ces sujets devraient
faire tranquillement ce marché que si on
bouge avec à faire en sorte que les
propos diffamatoires contre les femmes
ne soient plus autorisées on aura déjà
fait un grand pas et même en riant vous
ne pourriez plus vous êtes sérieux sur
dix ans que vous voudriez qu'on
m'interdise de ce genre de propos mais
je ne remets pas du tout mais je
voudrais qu'on mais pourquoi on voudrait
pas qu'on sourit comme ça de vous parler
de la journée du bim a alors atteint
enfin derniers mois de la vie
je voulais faire une bataille et pendant
je voulais faire une non je voulais
faire une remarque ce sens passé tout à
fait ce soir c'est à dire
qu'effectivement attendait ce que je
vaux mieux tout à fait c'est pas oui je
voulais faire une remarque sur ce qui se
passait ce soir et c'est effectivement
toute la question du féminisme
ils se trouvent vous avez invité un
homme et que le débat s'organise autour
de lui on lui a donné beaucoup plus la
parole numériquement il est seul il a eu
la parole franchement quand les femmes
qui étaient là non mais c'est très
important il suffit qu'un homme à un
endroit pour que ça a établi ce genre de
rapport pour ça c'est la réalité
bon l'autre chose qui est la question
effectivement que j'essaie d'aborder
tout à l'heure c'est que la diffamation
la diffamation c'est en fait porter
atteinte à l'honneur et il se trouve que
des femmes
non je vais ranger car expliqué son
travail à sa place
vidéo et se donne la parole au colisée
c'est mieux que les hommes
on se doute que les femmes non mais
laissez moi parler de minutes
il se trouve que l'afrique du sud a
gardé la mer sur gimont depuis des
millénaires et la misogynie c'est la
haine et mépris les phares une autre
victoire d'autant que la diffamation et
à des donations les couches de misogyne
ont redonné la parole je ne veux pas
regarder ailleurs
attendez je me rabats marie cardinal
nous donne la parole aux lycéens une
sortie attendait silence les lycéennes
je voudrais votre avis elles ont qu'elle
a commencé et d'ici là dedans dit ça
allait elle brûle d'impatience
avez vous eu de second jour de la
chambre si l'une à vos places aux jeunes
de maintenant jusqu'au 10 mai allez vous
n'avez pas intervenu depuis le début mai
le grand thème cette émission était
annoncé oui et c'était ce que la forme
était en deuil
ben arfa la voilà la question que je
pose la question sommes dans un débat
est là c'est une attaque de l'air bon
vous avez un problème
il ya aussi après le phallocratie c'est
à régler mais nous nous sommes venus ici
pour parler à propos du féminisme à
propos du 8 mars a composé de la cause
des femmes
à propos des problèmes de la femme il y
en a beaucoup nous en sommes tous
conscients tu et nous voulons débattre
alors moi je sais pas j'ai envie de
aussi en parler avec vous nous sommes
venus ici nous avons aussi beaucoup de
choses à dire
et puis bon jour alors dites-le
maintenant vous tout à l'heure vous
m'avez des bonds est ce que vous êtes
pour cette journée de la femme du 8 mars
par exemple pas tout à fait je suis
contre dans la forme c'est à dire que
pour moi
bon on essaye ils ont actuellement la
femme n'est pas là n'est pas égale à
l'homme
on le sait tout et on aimerait bien
disons par la suite être égale à l'homme
enfin c'est pas tellement de traction à
votre âge vous avez déjà le sentiment
d'avoir suivi d d d
des handicaps du fait d'être une femme
bien sûr chemin vous dire un exemple
dans mon lycée par exemple il ya des
discriminations sexistes dans les
classes et nos sens et non seulement
dans les sections
par exemple nous avons des voix
spécifiquement féminines et cela nous
nous voulons l'abolir par le moyen de la
coordination permanente icn deux
syndicats autogestionnaire des lycéens
nous voulons l'abolition des sections
spécifiquement féminines et ensuite il y
a des sections que nous ne pouvons pas
que nous pouvons pas atteindre
pourquoi parce qu'elles sont
spécifiquement masculine pourquoi alors
nous répond avec des réseaux vraiment
injustifiable disant que les femmes les
filles n'ont pas la maturité non pas
intellectuellement témoin des exemples
précis votre voisine là elle m'a dit
qu'il y avait par exemple une section
dépotoir on est pas qui est qui dessine
les femmes à être des dactylos ou des
secrétaires qu'on oriente après la 3e
directement chez vous pensez que ce sont
les filles pour les filles
et
les hommes on les envoie en est le père
oui moi je crois qu'il ya un problème
nettement aussi dans les lycées et au
lycée au chu on a essayé il ya deux ans
pendant leur vote de la loi veil de
faire un groupe femmes justement pour
essayer de de s'exprimer à l'intérieur
du lycée est parlé tous ces problèmes
qui est à bout on a mis du temps mais on
y arrivait avec de grosses difficultés
on a fait une exposition évitant les
femmes du planning familial en faisant
des débats dans les classes avec les
professeurs les élèves
ça a été particulièrement intéressant je
crois qu'il faut que ça se fasse dans
tout les lycées pour arriver à quelque
chose parce qu'il ya même une
discrimination envers les profs j'avais
un prof qui nous a dit il est traité
c'est comme les femmes ça ce viol alors
il ya une réaction dans la classe il ya
eu un silence est bon on n'a pas pu
tenir et ça a été trop dur vont les
on a commencé à avoir un débat très
houleux et ce professeur est en train de
parler de son service militaire à
l'avant à yahia - pays-bas va votre là
vous avez aussi ajouter quelque chose
moi ce que je pense c'est que si on fait
un combat tous ensemble il faudrait
également que les hommes participent
on était impossible que la femme
représente son gay simplement par elle
même il faudra aussi que l'homme donne
son accord pour confier pour préciser
soyez un petit peu plus précises tout à
l'heure vous avez l'air de me dire que
ce qui vous regrettez dans certains
mouvements féministes et qu'elle vous
pose des hommes et les femmes
voilà exactement yvon contrôleur ide et
c'est à dire les femmes veulent se
défendent et en fait elles font
également et comment elle elle mène
également une infériorité à l'homme on
traite aussi l'homme comme inférieures
alors qu'elle ne veut pas qu'on la
traite inférieur aux gains un dernier
mot et non justement
pour moi le 8 mars ça provoque une
division une division entre entre les
hommes et les femmes
nous nous luttons pour la fin de
l'exploitation pour la fin des
oppressions ce qu'il faut c'est en
commun l'église or il n'y aura jamais
merci tu t'attendais jane birkin vous
approuve crois que là on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]